why did you uh choose the uh song birch
grove to play today
you know i'm 53 and my kids are five and
two
and i look at them and i think are they
going to grow up without me
you know it's a reasonable thing to
think you know what i mean yep
um so i wanted to write this song as
kind of like a
like almost like a card from dad like so
you know it's like a road map it's it's
something maybe only they would
understand
so is it a confessional in a sense like
saying this is who i was
if you're listening this song when i'm
gone this is who your father was this is
what your father thought about
not what other people are gonna tell you
who i was or what i thought about this
is what i'm actually thinking about
i've seen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rain all alone
[Music]
won't you stand with me not someone
but someone else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
seedlings grow and crawl
in home if whatever ground
they hold shading life inside the fallen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but
[Music]
rain
[Music]
won't you stand with me not someone
not someone else
as my seedlings grow and grow
[Music]
[Music]
the butch croft stands for us
[Music]
beautiful